Es ist wieder Ligatour-Zeit, wir blicken auf den europäischen Fußball und diesmal gleich in 5 Ligen in die Ehredivise La Liga, Serie A, Ligue 1 und Premier League jetzt hier im Rasenfunk und los geht's! Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich begrüße hier bei mir in Reihenfolge ihre Bildschirme hier bei mir auf dem Monitor. Daniel Zander, guten Morgen Daniel.
Da muss man sich auch ein bisschen anpassen.
Solche Dinge werden momentan kritisiert und ich finde, er macht das fast schon ein bisschen zu ehrlich, zu offen. Weil dann denkt man sich, ja, dann machen wir es dagegen. Du bist der Trainer, du musst ja irgendwie Anpassungen treffen, wenn du immer wieder die gleichen Gegentore kassierst oder die gleichen Schwachstellen hast. Und wenn man dann so offen und ehrlich damit umgeht, erwartet man noch mehr Resultate. Und nach dem Transfersommer mit 500 Millionen ist Druck da, keine Frage. Also da merkt man momentan, Slot spürt den Druck. Und das war letztes Jahr so noch so eine Sache, dass Liverpool nie wirklich ernst Druck spürte, weil Liverpool, weil Arsenal City waren einfach nicht gut, hatten solchen Jahre, haben Liverpool nie wirklich gechallenged. Das war eigentlich Walk in the Park sozusagen, wie Liverpool den Titel am Ende geholt hat. Das soll überhaupt nicht den Titel mindern oder sonst was. Aber es waren dankbare Umstände am Ende und jetzt zum ersten Mal mit diesem Transfer, mit diesem Saisonstart kommt jetzt zum ersten Mal richtig Druck rein und man merkt, dass Slot sich da noch ein bisschen mit schwer tut.
Mario, du wolltest noch was sagen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich wollte mal nur Chris fragen, inwiefern das auch noch Thema ist, auch in den englischen Medien oder für dich selber auch, das mit Yoko Shota. Also ich kann mir jetzt auch sagen, ja, hat man schon vergessen, es ist schon wieder fast ein halbes Jahr her, aber ich finde, na gut, klar, da kommen dann auch neue dazu, aber die kommen dann in eine Kabine, in der die Stimmung wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so sein wird, wie sie dann in der letzten Saison war. Ich kann mir halt immer schwer vorstellen, dass das einfach irgendwie abgelegt wird und dann funktionieren wieder alle so wie davor.
Ja, keine Frage. Also am Anfang wurde schon mehr darüber geredet. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen in den Hintergrund gerückt. Und ich würde mir jetzt auch nicht persönlich jetzt irgendwie anmaßen, das zu beurteilen, wie ein Spieler damit umgeht oder nicht. Wir wissen es nicht, was für ein Effekt das in der Kabine hat. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es auf jeden Fall schwer war für die gesamte Mannschaft.
Das ist gar keine Frage.
Ich versuche mich halt bei der Analyse immer so ein bisschen an das zu orientieren, was ich beurteilen kann. Und die Probleme, die ich jetzt nannte, die nenne ich selbstbewusst, sage ich mal, weil man da schon Ansätze letztes Jahr gesehen hat vor dieser Tragödie, die einen emotionalen Impact hat. Und dieses Defensive-Umschall-Spiel, wackelende Defensive etc., die waren schon letztes Jahr da. Und deswegen haben wir ja auch in der letzten Folge im September drüber geredet, ob dieses Transferfenster so schillernd und glänzend es war, ob es wirklich so sinnvoll war, weil man einfach eine Stimme für 100 Millionen geholt hat, Probleme auf der Sechs hat, Probleme in der Verteidigung hat. Ja, dann holen wir noch eine Stimme für 150 Millionen. Und das sind so die Sachen, die man merkt. Aber ja, keine Frage, dass die Jota-Thematik, die Tragödie, die wird durchaus irgendwo eine Rolle spielen.
Es geht jetzt anspruchsvoll weiter. Heimspiel gegen Asken Villa, die sind aktuell punktgleich mit Liverpool. Heimspiel gegen Real Madrid und dann Auswärtsspiel bei Manchester City. Also das wird jetzt alles innerhalb von neun Tagen im November. Da wird sich so manche Weiche schon stellen. Wir werden es weiter natürlich genau im Blick behalten und gucken nochmal in die Niederlande. Daniel, worüber magst du noch mit uns sprechen?
Ja, so ein bisschen über Ajax nochmal, leider, muss man schon sagen. Ich hab so ein bisschen in den letzten Tagen die Analogie bemüht. Ajax ist so ein bisschen wie so ein Rätselheft am Bahnhof. So ein Sudoku, aber so ein Killer-Sudoku und irgendwie achtmal die Faktorzahl einträgt und wieder ausradiert. Weil ich werde auch nicht mehr langsam schlau aus dieser Mannschaft. Sie sind ja in der aktuellen Saison generell nicht so gut reingekommen. Jetzt nicht schlecht, immer noch auf Platz 4. Es ist okay. Es ist nicht der Anspruch natürlich, aber es ist okay. Es hat mit verschiedenen kleinen Sachen zu tun, die siehst du mir an. Das sind Transfers, da ist Hatto für 60 Millionen, glaube ich, weggebrochen. So Chelsea, da ist Probe im Sturm weggebrochen. Du hast viele Neuzugänge, die dich noch ein bisschen integrieren müssen. Klauk in der Offensive oder Hita Kura aus Lappbach gekommen. Du hast eben den neuen Trainer, da komme ich auch gleich noch mal drauf, auf den Heitinga. Es ist noch ein Mittelumbruch, nicht kleiner, auch kein riesiger, aber schon nennenswerter. Das führt dann eben dazu, dass du hier und da ein paar Punkte gegenlässt, auch gegen kleinere Mannschaften. Und dass die Taktik von Heitinga, der dieses Frioli-System ein bisschen angepasst hat, nicht mehr so stark offensiv spielen lässt, braucht noch ein bisschen Abstimmung. Das hat dazu geführt, dass man Punkte hier und da liegen gelassen hat, und mittlerweile auch den Trainer sehr staketisiert, weil er sich auch vercoacht hat, als ein oder andere Mal. In der letzten Folge des Rasenfunks, wo ich auch dabei war, gab es ja das Spiel in der Champions League gegen Marseille. Da hatten wir ja damals auch darüber gesprochen. Da hat er einmal gesagt, wir wollen offensiv draufgehen, wir wollten auf Preston das Flugheben damit ansagen, um die Ohren. Und jetzt haben sie gegen Chelsea in der Champions League wieder verloren. Und das war interessant, denn die ersten 10, 20 Minuten sah es eigentlich gut aus. Dann gab es eine rote Karte für Taylor von Ajax. Dann war es ein 5-1. Also dann, ja, lief es im Bach runter. Wobei aber man sagen muss, dass es bis dahin echt okay war, dass sie wirklich mal Ballbesitzphasen hatten, das konstruiert gespielt haben, jetzt nicht dominiert haben. Aber schon, wenn man sagen könnte, ey, wenn das so weitergeht, wenn sie das auch rechterhalten können, ist vielleicht ein Punkt drin. So war der Eindruck von diesem Champions-League-Spiel. Weil Heitinga auch ein bisschen überrascht hat. Er hat lange an seinem Team festgehalten, an der Startelf, und hat dann vor Chelsea relativ überraschend den Torwart gewechselt. Also hat Jarosz rausgenommen für den ewigen Passfär, der dann mal wieder spielt. Eigentlich auch eher so halb ohne Not. Also Jarosz war jetzt eigentlich relativ solide. Er hatte hier und da mal einen Wackeler, okay. Aber er würde für mich jetzt eigentlich nicht ausreichen, um zu rechtfertigen, wir müssen den jetzt von dem relativ wichtigen Champions-League-Spiel austauschen. Die ersten beiden Ligen verloren. Das heißt, klar, auch wenn der Name Chelsea relativ großer ist. Die läuft ja auch nicht alles rund bei denen. Da hätte man schon vielleicht sagen können, da brauchen wir jetzt nicht noch eine Torwart-Thematik. Na gut, war trotzdem aufgemacht. Dann wurde McConnel im Mittelfeld aufgestellt, das Startelf-Debüt gewesen für ihn. Also sehr viele Veränderungen in der Startelf. Ich war eher skeptisch, hat aber gut funktioniert bis zur Roten Karte. Und dann hast du gemerkt, da war die Hoffnung auch weg. Und da wurden die Beine irgendwann müde, was ich verstehen kann. Und dann stand Heitinga mit anderthalb Beinen schon vorm Rauswurf. Also medial, die nigerländischen Medien sind ja auch noch ein bisschen dreister und ein bisschen härter, was das angeht. Da wurde er ja eigentlich schon gefühlt, ach mal entlassen. Er hat sich aber noch gehalten, aus verschiedenen Gründen, die ich auch gleich nochmal kurz anreise. Und dann kommt dieses Rätselheftspiel gegen Twente Endsrede jetzt am Samstag, wo sie zur Haltzeit völlig verliebt nur zu einem Zurückliegen, Zurücklagen. Die haben auch dieselben Stadtwerfe genommen wie gegen Chelsea, weil man bis zur roten Karte dachte, es hat funktioniert. Und war man überhaupt nicht präsent, es hat eigentlich nichts funktioniert von dem, was Heitinga spielen lassen will. Und dann kamen sieben Minuten und drei Tore für Ajax. Und ich weiß nicht, woher diese sieben Minuten gekommen sind, in denen quasi fast alles funktioniert hat. In diesen sieben Minuten hast du mal gesehen, wie Heitinga Kurzpass spielen lassen will und wie es aussehen kann. Er möchte im Mittelfeld immer gerne ein bisschen überladen, zieht dann auch gerne mal einen Verteidiger noch rein, will irgendwie Räume schaffen, penkt die Flügelspieler-Szene. Es hat alles wunderbar funktioniert. Die waren passsicher, da war Einsatz drin. Plus noch individuelle Klasse von Klauch im Mittelfeld, von Wechhorst und auch von dem Talent Mika Horst. Das hat alles gut funktioniert. und die 3. stürzten auch. Und nach diesen 7 Minuten war es wieder vorbei. Dann war irgendwie wieder Rumpelfußball. Dann haben sie das 3-2 noch kassiert. Sie haben dann den Sieg mit Acher und Kraft über ihr Zeitgerät gerettet. Und ich werde nicht schlafen, was in diesen 7 Minuten passiert ist. Wenn wir diese 7 Minuten, wenn diese Spielanlage und das mal ausgedehnt werden würde auf einen längeren Zeitraum, dann würden wir auch von einem ganz anderen Ajax reden. Und da sieht man eigentlich, dass die Qualität im Kader schon da ist, trotz der tollen Verkäufe. Aber irgendwie haben sie es nicht geschafft, diese Phase bislang häufiger zu zeigen.
Aber kann Ajax aus diesem, wir feuern ein Trainer nach dem anderen, im Grunde seit, also man hat einen Tenhaktrauma, anders als Lirakusen. Aber seitdem ist es ja so, dass immer wieder, und das haben wir jetzt auch in den letzten Ligaturen immer wieder besprochen, kein Trainer darf eine ganze Saison machen oder selten mal eine komplette Saison. Und so richtig zufrieden ist man eigentlich nie. Kann man aus diesem Zirkel wirklich ausbrechen, indem man jetzt einfach nochmal einen neuen Trainer holt? Weil Heitinga war ja schon mal erfolgreich Trainer und er kommt aus der Jugend. Er hat natürlich auch eine Historie mit diesem Verein. Es ist allerdings, wenn ich es jetzt richtig gesehen habe, seine erste Station als Chef-Trainer. Das heißt, gewisse Anpassungsproblematiken muss man ja eigentlich auch eingepreist haben, wenn du so jemanden dir als Trainer holst.
Ja, also das Ding ist hinter vorgehaltener Hand. Es ist halt schon so, dass vor allem der Kostenfaktor auch mit Aufschlag geben war für Heitinga. Also es gab auch schon die Überlegung größeren Namen richtig zu holen. Aber andererseits wollten vielleicht auch die nicht so. Das ist die andere Wahrheit. Und eben der andere Faktor ist der Kostenfaktor. Und das ist auch, so hört man, wohl der Grund, warum Heitinga auch noch Trainer ist. Es hatte sich jetzt der technische Direktor Alex Cruz, der ist seit 2024 da. Kurz wie meint er, dass es der, der eben Anfang 2024 begonnen hat bei Ajax, damals doch als CEO, und wurde nach zwei Wochen beurlaubt aufgrund von Insider-Handel. Da hat er sich kurz vor seiner Berufung irgendwie ein paar hundert Aktien von Ajax noch gegönnt. Und nachdem dann dieses Thematik bisschen zugekommen ist, durfte er wieder zurückkehren und ist bis heute im Amt. Und der hat Heitinga geholt, damals ja von Liverpool, war ja Co-Unterslot. Und hatte jetzt vor, doch kurz vor dem Spiel gegen Chelsea, in einem Fanmagazin, in Ajax live, das ist so semi-professionell, also jetzt nicht nur ein Fanmagazin, aber schon mit 3 Tagen seiner Arbeit, aber jetzt kein klassisches Medium. Da hat er sich hingesetzt, eine Stunde in Podcast und hat so ein bisschen geplaudert. Und meinte auch dann, ja, wenn Heitinga geht, gehe ich mit, also er hat sein eigenes Sticksal gekoppelt an den Trainer, was für Ajax eigentlich letztendlich heißt, wir müssen zwei Leute neu ersetzen und zwei Leute weiter bezahlen. Und das ist bei Ajax schon ein großes Thema für die finanzielle Lage. Deswegen haben sie ja auch diese teuren Verkäufe letztendlich auch dann dann tätigt mit mit Hardtun und Propel und für weniger Geld eingekauft. Und das ist einfach ein Grund mit, warum der Hatinga noch Trainer ist, weil es einfach zu teuer wäre und man sich nicht leisten könnte. Ich halte es auch sportlich durchaus für sinnvoll, Hatinga eben jetzt nicht auch noch rauszuschmeißen, weil klar, wenn du diese hohe Fluktuation beibehältst, dann kann ja auch nichts letztendlich Gepästes bei rumkommen, weil dann hast du einen neuen Trainer, vielleicht einen neuen Spiel-Idee, dann wird das System wieder geändert, dann brauchst du wieder eine Anpassungsphase, ein bisschen schlimmes Hittenspieltag. Das ist auch bei entscheidender Phase, da ist ein 6-Punkte-Rückstand auf 1 und 2. Also wenn man jetzt noch einen neuen Trainer mit einer neuen Idee holen würde, der ja auch wieder irgendwie 10 Spieltage braucht, dann müsste er im Endeffekt auf 6 oder 7. Und dann muss er am Ende noch zusehen, dass du in die EL vielleicht noch kommst, was finanziell auch wichtig wäre, wenn du in die CL kommst und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, total. Vor allem, also müssen wir jetzt nicht noch weiter diskutieren, aber was man halt nicht aus dem Blick verlieren darf, wir argumentieren das immer vom einzelnen Verein aus und sehen dann eigentlich müsste Ajax besser sein und eigentlich braucht es doch nur zwei, drei Spieler und einen richtigen Trainer. Und dann müsste man doch eigentlich, und was aber in diesem eigentlich dann oft vergessen wird, ist, es gibt ja einen Wettbewerb. Und bei einem Wettbewerb muss man eben einfach sagen, PSV und Feyenoord, die haben Schritte gemacht in den letzten Jahren. Das haben wir ja auch hier immer wieder diskutiert. Das heißt, uneigentlich kann es sein, dass du mit einem anderen Trainer vielleicht leichte Fortritte machst und es trotzdem noch nicht reicht, weil die anderen sind nicht stehen geblieben in den letzten Jahren.
Ja, also ich glaube, Ziel für Ajax ist nicht Meister zu werden. Zumindest nicht in dieser Saison, vielleicht auch in der nächsten, sondern sich mal wirklich solide zu entwickeln, dass man vielleicht in der Tapest League nicht solche Klatschen bekommt, nicht so derbe Klatschen bekommt, dass man auch in der Liga gegen die kleineren Vereine mal Lösungen findet. Das ist dann klar, wenn sie sich da reinstellen, du dann auch unterhalb der Dinge auch schon merkst, so die wirklichen kreativen Ideen kommen da jetzt auch noch nicht. Dass du eben da diese Konzernz hast, weil das ist ja das, was PSV und Ferien Nord in den letzten Jahren geschafft haben. Peter Bosz ist ja auch schon jetzt relativ lange da und auch bei Ferien Nord mit Arno Slott hat er gut gearbeitet. Van Persie setzt die Arbeit da gut vor mit einer ähnlichen Idee. Also das passt auch. Da wurden auch Trainer so gegauchte, gegausht, dass sie zum Verein und zur Idee auch passen bei beiden. Und bei Ergst hat man das im letzten Jahr nicht so sagen. Da wurde dann auf andere Faktoren eher geachtet, wie eben Preis, Verfügbarkeit und vielleicht auch Namen oder Vereinsgeruch, Stahlgeruch. Das sind dann andere Faktoren, die da vielleicht den Aufschlag gegeben haben, auf die man vielleicht nicht vordergründig achten sollte. Aber ich hoffe einfach mal, dass diese sieben Minuten ausgeweilt werden können in den nächsten Wochen. Das würde mich einfach auch freuen.
Das ist ein wunderschöner, wunderschöner Buch.
Ich wollte nur eine Sache dazu sagen. Klar, kleine Samplesize, aber ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel mal Wout Wichors über insgesamt vielleicht vier Halbzeiten auch in der Länderspielpause bei der Nahti gesehen. Ich glaube, Limit ist erreicht bei ihm auch.
Du hast halt keinen Stürmer, das ist ja die Krux. Du hast Caspar Dolberg, der aber verletzt ist. Du hast mit Frobbe einen klaren Nummer neun verkauft. Und Heitinka spielt eben in diesen 4-2-3-1 aktuell mit einer Spitze. Da ist nur eine Spitze. Die anderen sind eigentlich eher Flügelspieler oder offensive Mittelfeldspieler oder auf jeden Fall nicht wirklich Durststürmer. Wobei, ich muss sagen, jetzt gegen Twente war er gut. Hat ihm gut gefallen. Aber klar, es ist keine 1A-Lösung, sage ich mal.
Also in den sieben Minuten von Angel, der hatte ja jeder gefallen. Das haben wir ja gestern schon rausgesucht.
Ja, das sowieso. Aber in den sieben Minuten waren alle top. Nur bei Bechorz ist halt das Problem, dass er auch konkurrenzlos ist bei Arags im Sturm. Da ist halt auch sonst niemand, der ihm da wirklich gefährlich werden könnte. Höchstens Dolberg, aber der ist eben noch geletzt.
Ja, also wir werden es im Blick behalten und mal gucken, wie sich Ajax da entscheidet. Und als du von Klatschen gesprochen hast, die man vermeiden wollte, da musste ich direkt an Jakob denken, also beziehungsweise an sein Thema natürlich, nicht an Jakob persönlich. Denn du willst mit uns noch über den FC Metz sprechen, Jakob. Der ursprünglich noch keinen Sieg hatte nach neun Spieltagen, aber jetzt, gestern war es, hat es tatsächlich mal geklappt. Gestern gab es ein 2 zu 0 gegen Lens, bedeutet aber trotzdem weiter letzter Platz, aber immerhin jetzt fünf Punkte und nicht mehr so komplett aussichtslos wie Anfang dieser Woche. Was ist denn da los bei Metz?
Ja, was ist los bei Metz? Also, ich glaube auch, hätten wir die Sendung jetzt nicht heute aufgenommen, sondern vielleicht gestern Morgen hätte man sicherlich noch drastischer über Metz gesprochen. Jetzt sind ja, glaube ich, dann die Wolves das einzige Team in den Top-5-Ligen noch ohne Sieg. Und da hat Metz sich jetzt also wirklich befreit und tatsächlich auch sehr beeindruckend gestern. Also, sie hatten, glaube ich, auch einen XG-Wert von über 3 in dem Spiel. Also, sie haben zwar die Tore erst in der 87. und in der Nachspielzeit gemacht, aber es war auch wirklich hoch verdient. Und das ja auch gegen Lens, über die wir wahrscheinlich gleich auch noch kurz sprechen, die ja auch durchaus ein gutes Team sind. Also, jetzt auch nicht gegen den Abstiegskonkurrenten, sondern schon eine beeindruckende Leistung. Aber man kann das jetzt natürlich nicht sagen, okay, jetzt ist alles wieder super, weil du hast es angesprochen vorher, zwei Punkte aus neun Spielen nur sieben Mal verloren. Man hatte den schlechtesten Sturm, hat die schlechteste Abwehr der Liga. Also, es sieht eigentlich alles nicht gut aus und man konnte das auch vor der Saison schon so ein bisschen ahnen. Also, man ist auch nur über die Relegation hochgekommen, ist also sozusagen auch schon rein nominell der schlechteste der drei Aufsteiger gewesen. Dazu kommt ja, dass bei den anderen beiden Aufsteigern, also Paris FC, haben ja wahrscheinlich viele mitbekommen. Die haben ja finanziell ganz andere Möglichkeiten. Bei Lorient war es so, dass die halt einfach auch in der letzten Saison schon deutlich besser waren, deutlich mehr Punkte geholt haben. Und ja, jetzt in dieser Saison lief auch in einigen Spielen ein bisschen was für die, aber über die wollen wir ja gar nicht sprechen, sondern über Metz. Und der Kader ist schon jetzt nicht so sonderlich gut, muss man sagen. Also, sie haben auch noch ein paar Leistungsträger verloren. Da muss man vor allem auch Udol nennen, der jetzt auch bei Lens tatsächlich spielt auf der gestrigen Gegenseite. Also, der war in der letzten Saison Kapitän, ist ein Verteidiger, hat aber, meine ich, auch sechs oder sieben Tore geschossen, hat auch in der Relegation getroffen. Also, wirklich so eigentlich einer der wichtigsten Spieler. Die beiden Topscorer aus der letzten Saison Gauthier Hain und Sheikh Sabali haben jetzt in dieser Saison, abgesehen von gestern im Falle von Hain, noch gar nicht wirklich funktioniert. Gerade bei Gauthier Hain, der ist jetzt auch schon 29. Und bei dem muss man auch sagen, dass der so ein klassischer– ja, ich bin in der zweiten Liga einer der besten, aber in der ersten Liga klappt es nicht so richtig. Spieler ist bisher gewesen, zumindest immer. Und ob sich das jetzt in dieser Saison ändert, muss man mal schauen. Die ersten neun Spieltage haben eher darauf hingedeutet, nicht unbedingt. Gestern hat er dann das 1-0 gemacht und auch das 2-0 hat dann sich danach das Trikot ausgezogen und ist noch mit gelb-rot vom Platz geflogen. Also auch eine sehr clevere Aktion. Ugo Ikitike lässt grüßen. Und ja, aber er kann halt, wenn er gut in Form ist, schon so der Faktor sein für Metz, weil er schon ein sehr spielstarker Offensivspieler ist. Ganz klein gewachsen, also körperlich auch, wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt auf dem Level, aber ist schon eigentlich ein ganz cooler Spieler. Und man hat dann dazu auch noch ein paar Neuzugänge geholt, die jetzt aber auch noch nicht so richtig eingeschlagen haben. Also im Sturm hat man mit Abib Diallo eingeholt, der hat in der Ligue 1 schon mal ganz gut performt, hat aber davor jetzt bei Al-Shabab gespielt und funktioniert jetzt auch bisher noch nicht gut in dieser Saison. Und ansonsten ist der Kader halt auch, ja, dann doch eher ein Zweitligakader als ein Ligue 1-Kader. Man hat zwar auch ein paar bekannte Spieler mit Jean-Philippe Géberman und Benjamin Stambouli, also zwei alte Bekannte aus der Bundesliga. Die Betonung liegt gerade bei Stambouli natürlich aber auch auf alt. Also, der ist jetzt auch schon 35. Er hat zum Beispiel am Wochenende auch gegen Lille nicht gut ausgesehen, Géberman aber auch nicht, wo sie ja 6 zu 1 verloren haben, auch sehr, sehr deutlich. Und bei Géberman muss man auch dazu sagen, der war ja auch wirklich in den letzten Jahren wirklich nur verletzt. Und da ist es überhaupt überraschend, dass er jetzt tatsächlich in den letzten Wochen zumindest mal wieder ein bisschen konstanter auch spielen kann. Der ist aber auch weit von seinem Mainz-Niveau momentan noch entfernt. Und grundsätzlich, ja, es ist schwer zu sagen, wie es bei Metz jetzt weitergeht. Ich meine, es kann natürlich sein, dass sie jetzt wirklich so das Gefühl haben, okay, wir sind jetzt angekommen und können uns jetzt wirklich zusammenreißen oder finden jetzt irgendwie was, was uns so richtig ausmacht. Weil das konnte ich jetzt zumindest in dieser Saison auch noch nicht so richtig identifizieren, was sie überhaupt wollen. Also wollen sie jetzt defensiv ganz kompakt stehen und dann auf Konter spielen, wenn das so sein sollte. Das sah zumindest gegen Lille so aus, da hat es aber halt überhaupt nicht funktioniert, weil sie die Bälle viel zu schnell verloren haben oder immer nur blind nach vorne gekloppt haben. Dementsprechend müssen sie da vielleicht so ein bisschen ihre Art und Weise finden, wie man denn dann überhaupt punkten kann. Das liegt dann natürlich auch so ein bisschen an Trainer Stefan Le Mignon, der jetzt aber auch auf dem Niveau, ehrlich gesagt, noch gar keine Erfahrung hat, ist im letzten Sommer, also ist mit ihnen aufgestiegen, hat davor aber nur bei kleineren Clubs trainiert, also Concano, Créteil, Boulogne und Wann waren seine Stationen davor, ist jetzt auch nicht mehr ein absolutes Talent mit 51. Aber ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass im Verein auch das relativ realistisch bisher noch betrachtet wird, was einfach die Ausgangslage ist. Und da war jetzt auch nicht sonderlich Alarm. Man hat jetzt noch nicht so viel gehört, dass Le Mignon so großartig unter Druck wäre. Und ich weiß auch nicht, inwiefern sich das jetzt ändert, wenn man zumindest jetzt so ein bisschen ab und zu mal auch punktet. Aber ich glaube, es ist schon nicht unwahrscheinlich, dass man wieder absteigt. Es ist in den letzten Jahren auch immer so gewesen, dass man hoch und runter gebounst ist. So ein bisschen, also Metz, der JuJu-Club schlechthin in den letzten– also in diesem Jahrtausend eigentlich waren teilweise auch in der dritten Liga und sind aber halt zumindest zwischen der zweiten und ersten Liga eigentlich relativ konstant immer hin und her. Und wenn sie mal ein Jahr den Klassen erhalt schaffen, steigen sie eigentlich im nächsten auch wieder ab.
Also so ganz überraschend ist es nicht. Aber um jetzt die Ehre von Metz zu retten, man war bei Weitem nicht das einzige Team, das gemeinsam mit den Wolfen noch sieglos war in der Liga. Wir haben in der Serie A Verona, Pisa, Florenz und Genua, die noch nicht gewonnen haben. Und dann schauen wir mal in die Bundesliga. Grüße nach Gladbach. Stimmt. Also ganz so schlimm ist es dann doch nicht.
Wo ich das gerade hergezogen habe, weiß ich auch nicht genau.
Ich war noch kurz überrascht und bei Gladbach war ich mir sicher und dann habe ich hier nochmal kurz durchgeklickt. Also das ist ja auch nicht ganz so überraschend. Aber wir wollen auch nochmal in die Serie A blicken. Da jetzt allerdings dann auch auf einen europäischen Vergleich. Denn es gibt noch ein Team, das in Europas Ligen ungeschlagen ist. Eins ist der FC Bayern und das zweite Mario ist Trommelwirbel.
Alain de Bergamo.
So nämlich.
Und sonst bin ich ja gerne auch mal dafür bekannt, dass ich auf die Trainer drauf haue und Christian Bernhardt immer den Advokaten spielt mit den positiven Aspekten. Und ehrlicherweise will ich das diese Woche gerne übernehmen. Ivan Juric hat auch in diesem Podcast, glaube ich, von der einen oder anderen Seite auch aus England, schon auf den Deckel bekommen und auch zurecht. Und wenn man sich das dann aber nochmal das große Bild zeichnet, ist eigentlich nur ein Jahr richtig schlecht gewesen bei Ivan Juric. Das war die Zeit bei der Roma. Er ist ein schwieriger Charakter und da wurde auch, glaube ich, aus Spielerkreisen nicht gut über ihn geredet. Allerdings waren das teilweise auch Spieler, bei denen immer die Trainer schuld sind. Man muss sagen, er hat bei Atalanta ein großes Erbe angetreten, mit Gian Piero Gasperini. Er ist auch ein Gasperini-Schüler, klar, das hat alles Sinn gemacht. Darüber, glaube ich, hat man schon einiges gelesen. Ich war auch trotzdem kritisch und dachte, kann das funktionieren? Und man muss sagen, es funktioniert spielerisch sehr gut. Einzig, sie machen die Tore noch nicht. Also dieses große Offensivfeuerwerk ist nicht da. Und wenn man sich nur die Ergebnisse der letzten Wochen anschaut, könnte man meinen, von außen betrachtet, ach guck mal, ja hier, klar, Ivan Juric ist da, jetzt spielen die immer nur 0-0 und 1-1. Ich habe mir nochmal die Mühe gemacht, mir eine XG-Tabelle anzugucken und auch Expected Points, da wären sie auf Platz 3 hinter Inter und Milan. Also sie haben auch in vielen Partien, klar, auch gegen Aufsteiger Cremonese, wo Jamie Wadi getroffen hat, im Übrigen zum ersten Mal, und der dann mit dem der Name hier mal getroppt wurde. Es gab mindestens zwei Spiele, wo man safe hätte, einfach zwei Punkte mehr mitnehmen müssen, dann würde alles ganz anders aussehen. Aber ich sehe bei der Mannschaft ganz viele positiven Aspekte. Lukeman hat es wieder getroffen gegen Milan, da gab es im Sommer das Ding, dass er sich wegstreiken wollte. Und dann hat Atalanta Stärke bewiesen, hat gemeint, nee, ist nicht genug, was Inter zahlt. Du bleibst hier, auch wenn du nicht trainierst. Dadurch hat er natürlich die ganze Saisonvorbereitung nicht mitgemacht. Aber das finde ich zum einen, war Atalanta schon immer konsequent bei sowas. Und dann auch noch diese Größe zu haben, zu sagen, okay, aber jetzt du willst wieder, dann spiel, integriere dich. Und er spielt, hat jetzt wieder getroffen. Klar, ihnen geht halt auch mit Retegi der Top-Torjäger der letzten Saison ab. Oscar Maka war mit einem Kreuz bei Dresden ganzes Jahr raus. Aber ansonsten sind da auch schon wieder ganz viele spannende Namen. Ihr könnt euch mal gerne Ahanor aufschreiben. Das ist ein 17-jähriger Junge in Italien geboren, nigerianische Eltern, spielt Dreierkette, als würde er schon zwei, drei Jahre Profi-Fußball spielen. Und alles, was es unter Gasperini auch gab, mit dieser Intensität durchverteidigen, die IVs-Rücken, das hatten wir jetzt gegen Milan. Da hat sich dann mal Rafa Leo, der Cheminist, tief bis in die eigene Hälfte fallen lassen, um sich Bälle abzuholen. Und Ahanor und Hiren, die Innenverteidiger, verfolgen die bis 30 Meter vor ihrem eigenen Tor. Also da ist ganz, ganz viel Spannendes mit dabei. Und wenn da dann der Knoten offensiv gesehen platzt, dann haben sie auch mit Charles de Quetelar immer noch einen, der auch nicht das Fußballspielen verlernt hat, freue ich mich sehr drauf. Bin selbst etwas überrascht, dass das so gut funktioniert, auch wenn es man in der faktischen Tabelle so vielleicht noch nicht wieder sieht, aber in den nächsten paar Wochen, Ende November, bin ich in Frankfurt im Stadion, da spielen sie bei der Eintracht, freue ich mich sehr drauf. Und wenn sich die Entwicklung so weiterzieht, dann glaube ich, muss die SGE sich da auf was gefasst machen.
Ja, es wird ja ein 5-1 in die eine oder die andere Richtung. So. Da kann man sich gerade...
Als erstes jetzt natürlich müssen sie erst mal noch nach Napoli, die Eintracht. Vielleicht gibt es da auch ein 5-1, auch ohne Kevin de Bruyne. Das habe ich ohne dass es gewerkt, dass mein drittes Thema untergebracht. Nein, aber das ist, wenn ich gerade drüber nachgedacht habe, nur dass ich es mal gehört habe, es ist so ein großes Thema, ist es natürlich auch gar nicht. Weil es schnell zu Ende erzählt ist, Kevin de Bruyne hat sich am Wochenende beim Elfmeterschießen den Oberschenkel zerschossen und ja, dachte es zum Muskelfaseriss, Muskelbündelriss. Na gut, dann sind es halt bei dem alten Mann vielleicht mal sechs Wochen, statt irgendwie wie bei dem 21-jährigen drei. Es ist so viel kaputtgegangen in diesem Oberschenkel, musste operiert werden, ist schon wieder in der belgischen Heimat, fällt vermutlich bis Februar aus. Das ist schon krass und extrem bitter.
Aber wie lange hat der vorher gespielt? Der wurde ja nicht eingewechselt vor diesem Elfmeterschießen.
Nee, das war ein Elfmeter im Spiel, erste Halbzeit.
Ach so, okay, alles klar. Ach so, bei einem Elfmeter. Ich dachte, das war ja gar kein Pokal. Ich war schon völlig verrückt. Ja, okay, ja, interessant. Ich meine, es gibt Trainer, die deswegen das auf das Tor schießen am Ende des Trainings verbieten bei ihren Spielerinnen und Spielern, weil das eine typische Bewegung ist, bei der noch mal eine Verletzung passiert. Also so hat Alex Pop zum Beispiel das EM-Finale verpasst. Vor drei Jahren ist es inzwischen her. Wenn du allerdings im Spiel schießt, ja, okay, da war schon... Also Kevin de Bruyne wird nicht mit dabei sein, das haben wir ja mitbekommen, aber dass es so übel ist, ehrlich gesagt, noch nicht. Danke dafür. Wir machen noch einen ganz schnellen Rundumschlag. Daniel, du hast uns noch was aus der Eredivise mitgebracht.
Genau, eine kleine Nachliste zum Topper, zur Fair Yard Road gegen PSV am Sonntag. War ein sehr spannendes und unterhaltsamen Spiel. Dauerte ein bisschen länger, ging nämlich 15, 20 Minuten später los. Es gab eine sehr, sehr große Choreo von Fair Yard Road mit sehr, sehr vielen Papierschnipseln. Es war auch sehr windig leider. Das heißt, die ganzen Schnipsel haben dann auf dem Spielfeld gelegen, haben die Linien blockiert, dann kamen auch die…
Wenn Major Rieke immer noch grinst, wenn eine Papierkugel auch nur angedeutet wird, das ist ja umflachlich.
Da wird rochennal. Wir erinnern uns. Aber das war jetzt so flacher Schnipsel-Air, also keine Gefahr, dass da Ecken resultieren. Jedenfalls kamen irgendwann die Laubbläsertruppe, die dann versucht hat, gegen den Wind zu arbeiten, der von außen kommt. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Dann kamen irgendwann die Rechenschieber. Und irgendwann hatte man dann die Linien frei, und dann konnte es auch losgehen. Und es hat Paysway gewonnen mit 32. Es war ein sehr unterhaltsames Spiel. Das war das erwartete Spiel von Platz 1 gegen Platz 2. Ein paar Sachen waren schon auffällig. Einmal hat Robin van Persie in die Trickkiste gegriffen bei Feyenoord und Sam Steyn, eigentlich den Topspieler dieses Teams, auf der Bank schmoren lassen. Bis tief in die 80. Minute rein, was sehr ungewöhnlich war. Aber davor war er Stammspieler. War jetzt auch nicht in einem Formtief oder so. Und er hat es dann nachbegründet. Sie wollten etwas Taktisches ausprobieren. Hat dann nicht ganz genau gesagt, was. Vermutlich, weil es nicht funktioniert hat. Es war der Gedanke, der sich aufdrängte, dass man wirklich ein bisschen defensiver agieren wollte, im Mittelfeld ein bisschen mehr Krib haben will. Dann kam Valente, Führst du in die Semmstrasse, den Startelf, der dann ein Tor erzielt. Also ganz verkehrt war es nicht. Aber den wirklichen Zugriff im Mittelfeld, der gewünscht wurde, so wie es aussah, den gab es dann trotzdem nicht. War aber trotzdem ein enges Spiel, in dem Feyenoord auch gut und gerne das 3-3 hätte machen können. Am Ende gab es dann mal einen Sturmlauf. Ich hatte ja gesagt, in der letzten Ausgabe, in der ich dabei war, Feyenoord wird Meister. Ich bleibe auch dabei. Wir sind ja nach Platz 1, danke, Tor-Deferenz. Bei Feyenoord, vielleicht aus deutscher Sicht interessant, dass Paul Wanner bislang wirklich gar keine Rolle spielt. Er saß auch wieder nur auf der Bank und kommt nicht so zum Zuge, weil einfach Mann, den haben sie neu geholt, einfach stark spielt, weil Peresic sein x-Ton-Fühling erlebt und weil es einfach ein funktionierendes Gebilde ist, diese Offensive von PSV. Und da dann reinzukommen, von außen ist eh nicht ganz so leicht. Und bei Männer läuft es einfach noch nicht. Es wird oft dann erst in der letzten halben Stunde, wenn die überhaupt eingewechselt sind, sieht er eher unglücklich aus als glücklich oder als schlecht ist. Aber er hat da noch nicht so die Bindung zum PSV. Spielt vielleicht aus deutscher Sicht noch interessant. Und was auch noch spannend ist, das Flamingo, den habe ich ja auch sehr, sehr häufig hier zu Recht auch gelobt in der Abwehr, ist auch eher auf der Bank mittlerweile. Da hat man Gasiłowski geholt aus Valencia, Junker Elfmetalliker, der hat ihn verdrängt so ein bisschen. Und was auch noch erwähnenswert ist als als Punkt bei PSV, Salaheddin. Der ist so ein polyvalenter Spieler, der hat, glaube ich, bis auf im Tor eigentlich auch schon jetzt überall mal auf allen Positionen gespielt bei PSV. Er war jetzt links hinten und hat es auch gut gemacht. Das sind so die kleinen Erkenntnisse auf dem Spiel.
Und dass Saibari jetzt nicht so schlecht gespielt hat bei drei Treffern, das ist ja auch klar.
Genau, jetzt war er der absolute Match-Winner, der, wo man auch wieder sieht, dass der wirklich aus allen Lagen gefährliche Situationen kreieren kann. Der hatte einen relativ spitzen Winkel, ich glaube, beim ersten Tor, beim letzten Tor, beim dritten Tor, hatte er, glaube ich, Lupfer sich ausgeguckt, der genau wunderbar über Torwart und Latte sich reingesenkt hat. Der hat Technik, der hat Auge, der macht Spaß. Und er dreht jetzt auch so ein bisschen mehr in den Fokus, weil ja eben Bakayoko jetzt zu Leipzig gegangen ist, weil auch ein Tillmann zu Refakus gegangen ist. Das heißt, da kriegt er mehr Spielzeit und die nutzt er natürlich jetzt auch sehr, sehr gut.
Das ist sowieso für mich das größte Versäumnis vom PSV. Man hat jetzt Till und Mann auf dem Feld, aber Tillmann nicht. Ja, das wäre so naheliegend gewesen.
Ich habe dich ja gegen Napoli auch gesehen über 90 Minuten. Da, wie du es schon gesagt hast, so viele Zocker und auch Perisic immer noch die Linie rauf und runter marschieren. Und wenn du ihnen Räume gibst, dann haben die also so ein Team, das Spielfreude Stichwort. Und du guckst einfach gerne zu.
Defensiv müssen sie sich immer ein bisschen finden. Das ist nicht ganz so einfach, weil es dann so offensiv ist.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch gut für mich dann immer.
Genau eben.
Noah Lang bereut schon den Wechsel.
Das definitiv.
Schauen wir mal, wenn wir ja unter anderem auch noch gegen Bayern sehen, dann zu Hause. Das allerdings dann erst im Januar. Also wird noch eine ganze Weile dauern. Aber PSV, lohnt es sich im Auge zu behalten. Daniel, du musst weiter. Ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich für deine Zeit hier im Rasenfunk. Bis bald mal wieder.
Ja, bis bald. War immer schön.
Macht's gut.
Du auch. Und wir schauen nochmal nach England. Chris, was hast du uns da noch mitgebracht?
Ja, nun eine kleine Statistik. Ich meine, ich bin es jetzt gewohnt, dass der Rasenfunk mich immer ein bisschen alt fühlen lässt bei den ganzen Spieler, Söhnen oder Trainern. Also Spieler jetzt Trainer. Und da habe ich noch was, um das Ganze so ein bisschen zu bestärken. James Milner hat nämlich Geschichte geschrieben im Wochenende und hat für Brighton eine Vorlage geliefert für Barbies Kostulas zum zwischenzeitlichen 2-3 gegen United. Und das beeindruckende an der Geschichte war, dass es das erste Mal war, dass ein Spieler eine Vorlage für einen anderen gegeben hat, der nicht geboren war, jetzt muss ich es noch in der deutscher Grammatik hinkriegen, der nicht geboren war, als der Vorlagengeber schon in der Premier League gespielt hat. Das heißt, James Milner hat mit 16 sein Debüt für Leeds gegeben. Und als James Milner 21 war, wurde Kostulas erst geboren.
Also 5 Jahre später.
Ich hoffe, ich habe es jetzt einigermaßen verständlich rübergebracht.
Es ist ein ganz wunderbarer Fun-Fact. Und ja, man fühlt sich da bei alt. Aber das geht mir ehrlich gesagt die ganze Zeit so, wenn es hier heißt, ja, mit 35 hat er ja auch so das Ende seines Zenits erreicht. Aber gut, sehr schön, James Milner, der ewige James Milner. Jakob, du hast auch noch was Kleines aus der Liga.
Genau, zu James Milner noch kurz ist mein absoluter Lieblingsspieler und er wird ja wahrscheinlich diese Saison auch noch den nächsten Rekord brechen.
Und zwar?
Den Allzeit-Einsatz-Rekord von Gareth Barry. Ich glaube, da fehlen ihm ja auch nur noch acht oder neun Spiele, um die meisten Einsätze in der Premier League zu sammeln. Also der englische Karl-Heinz Körbel.
Aber wirklich. So wird er auch in der Premier League immer schon genannt.
Genau, natürlich. Ich wollte nur ganz kurz noch über L'Anse sprechen. Genau, die wären, glaube ich, das Hauptthema der Sendung geworden. Vielleicht sogar hätten sie gestern nicht verloren, also haben sich da eine große Möglichkeit verspielt, mit der 0 zu 2-Niederlage in Metz. Und sie stehen aber tatsächlich trotzdem noch ganz gut da, sind voll dabei, zwei Punkte hinter PSG, jetzt nur noch auf Platz 6. Und was besonders bemerkenswert ist, ist der Trainer an der Seitenlinie, Pierre Sage, der hat im Sommer erst übernommen. Da war ja Will Still Trainer, der jetzt in Southampton ja auch nur so mäßig erfolgreich ist bisher, so wie ich gehört habe, ja auch kurz vor der Entlassung sogar steht teilweise. Und da war so ein bisschen unklar, wie es bei Lens weitergeht, aber mit Pierre Sage haben sie da einen echt guten Mann gefunden, der wurde ja in der letzten Saison bei Lyon auch von vielen sehr kritisch gesehen, dass er da rausgeschmissen wurde und dann Paulo von Seca geholt wurde, weil er bei Lyon eigentlich auch super erfolgreich war, hatte die ja damals in der Vorsaison, also 23, 24 meint ich, im Abstiegskampf übernommen und dann noch fast bis nach Europa oder sogar bis nach Europa geführt und dann eigentlich auch einen ganz guten Saisonstart hingelegt. Und er ist so ein bisschen der französische Shooting-Star auf der Trainerbank neben Regis Le Brice vielleicht bei Sunderland und hat jetzt auch tatsächlich historisch einen richtig guten Punkteschnitt in der Liga. Also hat jetzt sein 51. Spiel gegen Metz gehabt, hat einen Punkteschnitt von 1,86. Das ist Platz 13 seit 1932 in der ganzen Liga. Also echt bemerkenswert. Also für alle Trainer über 50 Spiele. Und ja, Lens spielt auch einen ganz ansehendlichen Fußball. Ist jetzt nicht das allergrößte Offensivfeuerwerk, aber sie stehen halt hinten auch ganz gut. Haben zwei interessante oder zwei altbekannte Namen auch dabei mit Ozzon Edouard, der im Sturm jetzt auch ganz gut eingeschlagen ist, seitdem er da im Sommer ist. Und dann natürlich Florian Thauvin, der er sogar so gut spielt, dass er wieder für Frankreich auch nominiert wurde. Und dazu ist Lens auch sehr stark bei Standards. Also da haben wir nochmal die Replik an das Arsenal-Segment vorher. Auch das hilft da sehr gut. Muss man mal schauen. Ich kann mir aber gut vorstellen, dass Lens zumindest auch längere Zeit um die Champions League-Plätze mitspielen könnte und auf jeden Fall durchaus in Europa landen kann. Auch wieder sehr schön.
Die Sage Saga. Sie geht weiter. Ihr inzwischen nur noch drei. Ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Also nie mussten wir schon vorher verabschieden aus technischen Problemen. Daniel wegen terminlicher Probleme und euch dreien, sage ich jetzt wegen inhaltlicher, nämlich weil es das Ende der Sendung ist, sage ich euch jetzt danke. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an euch drei. Majorika, Chris McCarthy, Jakob Haffke. Danke für eure Zeit und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, für eure Unterstützung. Ihr wisst, alles im Rasenfunk ist von euch finanziert. Hier gibt es keine Wettsponsoren, hier gibt es keine sonstigen Sponsoren. Es gibt auch keine Werbung und das alles nur, weil ihr uns finanziell unterstützt auf rasenfunk.de. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Oder ihr klickt einfach auf die Videobeschreibung. In dieser Sendung möchte ich mich bedanken bei Michael, bei Bären, bei Roland, bei Simon und bei Fahnen. Vielen herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Und wenn ihr auch nach dem Zufallsprinzip hier erwähnt werden wollt, dann könnt ihr euch noch registrieren auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und dann kann es sein, dass ich euch hier auch mal persönlich danke. In diesem Sinne, verbreitet diese Sendung gerne weiter, werdet oder bleibt gesund und bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank!